i'm going to start with uh
congratulations on the movie i'm sure
you're hearing that from everybody
coming through it's a very hard day to
do press i'm sure thank you yeah thank
you
um so something i read was that
originally uh uh liv schreiber was gonna
actually be this to do this role and
then you know the scheduling pandemic
and you ended up with it so i guess my
my main question is have you sent him a
thank you card for uh letting you be uh
you know for um for you know dropping
out because
you know what i mean
i should i still only have that thank
you card um you've you've reminded me my
manners are very bad
but hopefully i'll give it to him in
person yeah
um one of the things that's just crazy
about this story
is
like how truthful it is like this if you
had written this as a hollywood script
people would be like this is so
far-fetched this would never happen take
it out of the room it's never going to
go um but it's true when when you were
researching and reading about all this
in their story were there what were some
of the things you learned that you're
like this can't be true but it is oh
yeah when i read this script i i was
shocked because i knew that serena and
venus's father had been involved in
their career and had coached them when
they were young
but
when i read that
that
richard williams happened to be before
serena and venus were even born he was
watching a tennis match on television uh
a woman you know one young woman won a
tennis tournament and uh you know got
paid 40 000 for a week of playing tennis
and
he said that is what we're gonna do and
we're gonna you know there are no this
is an all-white sport and we're gonna
we're gonna make history here and he's
he went to his wife orricin and said
we're gonna have two more kids they're
gonna be two girls and they're gonna
we're gonna
train them and they're going to become
number two and number
number one and number two in the world
at this game
and he wrote a 75 to 80 page manifesto
detailing how that was going to happen
that if you told me that i would have
said that's crazy that never happened
and it's all absolutely true
um what for for for soon to be fans of
this movie
what do you think might surprise them to
learn about the actual making of the
film
um
i i mean these days people are so
smart about how movies are made i'm
thinking of so much information so the
actual making of it it was we made it
during the pandemic
so it was one of the you know and it was
my first job back working in the
pandemic when things were very very
uncertain and um the protocols had just
been put into place and everyone was you
know heavily masked and
we didn't know if we'd be able to you
know get it done and you came to work
and there was this giant production and
with you know
hundreds of people working
with the whole covid team which was a
new thing and it was a tremendous
obstacle it's getting it made but it was
also
you know very inspiring to see a group
of creative artists saying we're going
to soldier through and
and and you know tell this story
together and it gave us some i think
everyone gave everyone um i don't know
it was it was quite inspiring to be a
part of you know that no matter what as
the world was really
um
you know
falling
falling apart around our you know around
us uh
to everyone to rally and do this work
was was was pretty cool um
you know and then that became the norm
and and we sort of
projects figured out how to do and then
the next project and the next project
you know now we're all used to wearing
masks on set and stuff but a year ago it
was some
it was a different story it was it was
very bizarre
on that note i have to stop i'm just
going to say seriously congratulations
uh great work and great thanks i
appreciate that thanks a lot man